we're just about to 420 we got a pretty
good crowd in here
late afternoon but I'm gonna hopefully
hold your attention because I'm up here
giving you a sales pitch on something
I'm very excited about which is graph QL
so graph QL is an interesting
alternative to the way that many people
have been doing api's throughout the
years and what makes it interesting is
rethinking who has power in this
situation for the longest time we have
said the server has the power but graph
QL says what if the client had a lot
more declarative power what if we had a
really clear spec that could outline
this so let me begin by getting to know
the room how many of you in here would
say that you build rest api's there we
go and yet you still showed up with my
linkbait title here so you're in here
still smiling for the most part that's
good to see
willing to try this out so that was the
majority of the room I would say how
many of you are doing more RPC style
standing for a remote procedure call
style api's nobody claims our PC Wow
usually you get a few hands there I'd be
interested to see some of you that are
saying you're doing rest maybe doing
something that's a little more RPC be
interesting to see who's doing soap
there we go but that was a random image
generator I had no idea what would pop
up there but strange coincidence yeah
I've done so pi it wasn't my favorite
thing but it did have its time for sure
and it's also interesting because graph
QL much like soap soap has a big
complicated specification well graph QL
has aspect too and that's one of the
things I'm going to fixate on is the
beauty of having a spec that that really
is a good thing who in here who am i
preaching to the choir already doing
graph QL nobody okay good so if I say
something wrong nobody can call me on it
all right
we'll move on there so what we're going
to do to begin I want to
you a feel for graph QL now one way I
could do that is I could go out to
github site and you can feel free to do
so on your own I'm actually going to
just run something local because it's a
little more approachable but a great way
to get a feel for the power of graph QL
is not surprisingly to use the darn
thing so I have started up over on my
local machine in instance of a graph QL
server and we'll get into how the thing
actually works in a moment but what I
want to show you to begin is me
interacting with a graph QL endpoint and
I'm gonna do that using a tool called
graphical it's a pretty catchy name I
like it
graphical is a UI that comes out of the
box when you have a graph QL server to
have this documentation experience that
I'm about to show you I set a boolean to
say yes please so I want to emphasize
that the goodness I'm about to show you
is free of charge which is a revelation
if you're somebody that has worked in
other API technologies where the
documentation story is well I don't know
maybe we should go check out swagger or
maybe we should roll our own these sorts
of things no this is because of the spec
just generated so what we have is Docs
over here on the left hand side when I
pull this up you can see I have this
Doc's tab so I can start to click
through and see what types of data we're
working with here so my graph QL API
deals with posts deals with users and
deals with comments so you can see this
is really related to a blog so I can
come over here and I can decide that I
want to make a query now notice the
moment I typed Q I have autocomplete
support here with in graphical so I'm
going to hit tab and start my query my
query is going to look a little bit like
JavaScript but this is graph QL s query
language so right here I can begin to
write my query I'm hitting control space
to get autocomplete support along the
way here so you can see already these
are the things that I can query for
maybe I want to look for a single post
or maybe I want to look for all the
posts so just give me all the posts
right here and I want the ID for the
post and I want the title for the post
I'm going to come up here and hit play
look at that I got my data what if I
want a little bit more data I'd also
like the views the number of views for
this post here's what I'm getting on the
right do you already see the goodness
going on here
I am on the client I could make a call
and say this is precisely the JSON that
I want and that's what I get this is a
revelation because how many of you in
here right now have an API that allows
the client to say I want these
particular properties on this exact
object who in the room can do that no
hands go up and that is interesting
because if you think about if I came to
you and I said hey the requirements are
when somebody requests a user they need
to be able to request specific
properties you can probably imagine in
your head well I could make that happen
but I need to come up with a way to do
so that means I've got to support maybe
some kind of a query string where
somebody says fields and then they could
put in a comma delimited list of fields
that they might want properties that
they want on that object
so you'd more or less come up with your
own way to solve it as a programmer so I
think all of us in here understand that
what I'm doing just right here isn't
technically a huge hurdle I believe that
the reason that this room isn't doing
what I just showed you is because
there's no spec that's telling you that
you should and in fact what I'm getting
right here is free because I'm using
graph QL I get to tell the server what
data I want now the plot gets nicer too
because I can end up requesting nested
data I could come in here and also say
that I would like the comments
associated with the posts that I get
back and when you give me those comments
I'd like the body for the comment and
I'd like the date that that comment was
entered now check that out
now I have just gotten relational data I
chained from the post over to the
comment life is good
like when I saw this this is what got me
really excited about graph QL because I
thought I have seen in my career about
two api's that let me do this that let
me say I want to go from here to here to
chain relationships and again when you
think about it you could write the code
to do this you if you went back to your
desk you could make it happen but the
way that you do it and the way that you
do it would be different and that's not
necessarily wrong but every time the
developers are out there solving a
problem
ad hoc we're sort of reinventing the
wheel and the question is why what I'm
showing you is this idea of a client
requesting data from the server in a
specific format is a solved problem now
with graph QL because the specification
gives it to you for free so if you
choose to use a graph QL server and
describe your data using a graph QL
schema then this experience becomes your
reality so how many of you in here have
an API that allows you to chain through
relationships of entities in a single
query one hand but it was only like
halfway up I don't know if that was oh
okay so it's it's more it's almost a
custom endpoint then you'd say so sort
of an app specific API which those are
very common and those are useful and in
fact there's some real benefits of that
too because you can tweak that exact
call to be perfect for that particular
use case too so we have now requested
some some data along here now graph QL
isn't just about queries though I also
have the opportunity to change data so I
could come into here and write a
mutation Oh
before I do I wanted to show one other
thing I can also
declare oops
there we go I can also declare names
that are custom for properties if you
ever had this before where somebody
publishes an API but you don't like the
properties that have been sent back on
those objects you'd like to be able to
tweak some of the names in the JSON well
now instead of me having to iterate over
some array of a hundred values and
change a few properties in that array in
a loop over in JavaScript on the client
I tell the server when you give me the
title from the database which is a type
of string I can see that from the
metadata I want you to name that value
as my title instead of title so notice
that now the JSON that I get back again
honors my request so see how all of a
sudden a lot of power has shifted from
the developer who wrote the API over to
the UI developer who is saying I need
some JSON and I need it to look this way
and it'd be really nice if I could make
one HTTP call instead of 17 because I
got to go chain from here to here to
here to here and manipulate all this
data to get it into a shape I want
so a reality for somebody who's working
with graph QL is chances are you can
make one call to get the data that you
need and to get it in the shape that you
desire which is super luxurious okay so
let's go back to the beginning because I
mentioned that this story isn't just
about queries it's also about mutations
so when I say mutation I mean changing
data now again notice how oh is my font
size big enough back row okay good
notice how I clicked over here and now I
can see again the different ways that I
can manipulate data in this particular
API I can create a post update a post I
can create comments remove comments
those sorts of things so let's say that
I want to create a post well I come over
here and I write mutation and then for
my mutation I want to call notice how
again I
autocomplete support so I can see this
is a discoverable API I can see the
things that I can do to mutate data and
notice that it is only showing me
mutations now since it knows that I'm
declaring a mutation so I would like to
create a post and notice this as well I
know what I need to pass to it and it is
prompting me I need to pass an ID and
yes I admit this example it's weird that
I'm passing an ID I'm I'm on the client
telling the server what ID that's not
normally the way you would structure
graph QL but just deal with the oddity
here it made my demo a little bit
simpler I'm using a tool that lets me
take some chunk of JSON and then stand
up a graph QL server it is mind-blowing
how simple this thing is so I'll show
you how this works next but let's first
get our first mutation to go here so
we're going to set the title - I love
graph QL and we're going to set the
views - let me move this over some I'm
going to close out this as well so we
can see it set the views to a hundred
and what am I forgetting here user ID
will set - oh let's see - 54 I think is
a relevant or a valid user ID
now here's pay attention because here's
where things get interesting again so
you look at this and you go well man
that almost it looks a lot like a
function call except I'm naming each one
of the arguments in the function call
but here's where it's going to do
something else that I bet none of your
api's do right now I can say after you
write this
give me back certain properties on that
object give me back the ID or give me
back the title so I can declare what I
want in the response when I'm making a
mutation anybody have an API that does
that right now
no hands again and again if I said you
need to do this I believe that anybody
in this room as a programmer you'd go
yeah I can code it I can make it happen
but none of us would do it the same way
so having a specification it's not just
about the fact
that it this is technically really hard
to do it's about the fact that you
literally don't have to do anything good
stuff that you're likely to enjoy is
just there in the box so that's part of
what gets me excited about graph QL so
I'm going to hit the play button here
and when I do notice that I got a
response and the response contains
precisely what I asked for now that I
did this if I come back over let's see
whether my data comes through here I've
got my query I've this time want to see
all posts and for all the posts I just
want to see the title that'll be good
enough and there it is oh I guess I have
to in here I already had one in there
that was called I why I love graph QL
but this was my new one right here and
in fact we could prove that if I also
bring back the ID there we go
and as a side note you don't have to put
the query in here in your query because
it is inferred it's basically the
default so if I leave query out then
oh it's unhappy because I am missing a
curly brace but there we go oh and in
fact I believe I can do oh no I can't I
need those on the outside there we go
so query is inferred as the default so
we have now done multiple things that
nobody's API is today are doing which is
pretty striking how many of you believe
that this would be useful okay so you
feel like I did when I saw this I was so
giddy I mean I'm basically here speaking
on this because I just want more people
to use it so hopefully my next dev job
I'm working with graph QL increase the
chances because as a front-end developer
I'm a front-end developer I work and
react a lot so politically I often don't
have enough power to force people to
change their API structures but I'm
convinced that if more of us move to
this structure we're going to have
better api's that are more flexible for
people let me back up and tell you why
graph QL
exists at all Facebook Facebook created
graph QL they created it to scratch
their own itch not surprisingly so
Facebook has one of the highest traffic
websites in the world and what do you
know also one of the most heavily used
mobile sites in the world and what they
had was API for the website API for the
mobile site and they said okay why are
we maintaining two api's wouldn't it be
nice if we could just have one API that
worked for both and you can imagine why
they had two separate ones because the
mobile app they said we only need a
little bit of the data because we're
only doing some of the features and the
web we need lots of data because we've
got all the features well once you
recognize this they design graph QL
deliberately to say you know what we
could build one API if we can come up
with a way for the client to say what it
wants so you think about the level of
flexibility here if I stand up an API
and graph QL somebody go build the UI
that since the UI is now declaring what
it wants it's no longer a situation
where you go in oK we've got to go do
API work to support this user interface
now if as long as graph QL is exposing
the data you're done because you merely
need to convey to graph QL what your
requirements are okay so I told you that
my demo was wildly simple and it is so
my first demo what I want to show you is
the code involved here so I am working
in node how many of you are familiar
with node probably lots of hands okay
and as JavaScript developers we work
with node a lot what I'm using is a tool
called JSON graph QL server this package
is crazy crazy useful very very simple
and in fact as a side note has anybody
used JSON server okay not enough hands
there so even if you decide graph QL
isn't for you today go check out JSON
server it's the free I say free it's
free it's open source but it is the same
thing as what I'm showing you here but
for traditional restful api s again I
say restful here because restful doesn't
really mean anything
- everybody consistently we all disagree
on exactly what a restful api is I won't
keep doing
because at some point my arms are get
tired but yeah so let me show how this
actually works this is it I put some
JSON in a file it parsed that JSON and
gave me everything that you just saw
does that blow your mind when I tried
this because it says on there Docs
they're going go ahead stand up a graph
QL server in 30 seconds I thought well
that's a bold statement and I had it
stood up in about 45 seconds cuz Wi-Fi
was slow it's it really is well done now
of course there's a massive amount of
magic going on here so let's look at
something that's potentially a little
more interesting or I should say a
little more realistic let me come over
and switch we're going to go over to
Express graph QL so here I'm going to
show you a graph QL server configured to
run via Express so it's going to start
right up this one's running on localhost
5,000 so this looks just the same it's
open graphical now given this is serving
different data this has some blog data
has some posts in it and then we can see
the different pieces of data that it has
here
excuse me but again I can come over here
and query whatever I like although this
is a relationship with an author here so
I would need to pull in maybe the
author's name something like that and
now I have gotten some more here so how
does this actually work again
surprisingly little code twenty lines of
code okay that's not fair it's not the
only file but still okay so Express
assuming you're familiar with Express I
am instantiating Express and I'm pulling
in this package called Express graph QL
which connects a graph QL server with
Express to make that connection I much
like other Express middleware I call app
dot use and I tell it hey here's the
schema for my API we're gonna look at
the schema in a second I want you to
pretty print the JSON and here's the
that really makes me smile that
graphical tool that we're looking at
it's a boolean
would you like Docs yes please done that
I love that piece
so I say app dot listen and it starts it
so let's go look at the schema because
the schema will give you a sense for how
this is put together and here we go
okay I'm gonna collapse the side of this
graph cue all schemas or strongly typed
and that's why we were over there able
to see that this fields an integer this
field is a string and so on so we come
in here and we say okay I've got this
author and that author is a graph QL
object here are the fields on that
object and here's the name that I want
you to display same story with a post a
post has an ID has a field and notice
here this is a post that has an author
and that author ends up having its own
content here its own type so we can go
look at the author which is declared
right down here below that an author has
these fields so I'm imagining how many
of you are C sharp for Java devs
probably lots of hands there we go
so you're familiar with types already so
you think about this this is not much
different than declaring a class but
you're following a unique structure here
for graph QL to declare these types and
once you do this you are following a
specification so since we're following a
spec this experience that we just saw
right here happens this is the beauty of
having a spec rather than having the
responsibility for building from scratch
now the magic for all of this comes down
to resolvers resolvers within your
schema so what I want to point out here
is look right here see this resolve
property
this is where I tell graph QL how to get
the data so in this case I'm saying look
in data and called get author well if I
show you data in this case is hard-coded
data over here in a file I did that for
simplicity but imagine instead that I'm
making a query to a database or imagine
that I'm making a call to your API today
that's really what I'm suggesting here a
bunch of us in here I asked at the
beginning how many of you raise your
hands have restful api zorse obey p eyes
and not surprisingly everybody raises
their hand for one of those two or three
options the beauty of graph QL is you
leverage all of that stuff that you've
done right now and you can end up
calling them from graph QL you can end
up putting this experience in front of
your existing api's and by doing so you
suddenly get the ability to say okay I
just want some of the data instead of
all of the data or I want these
relationships along the way and the way
that that happens is through your
resolvers so these resolvers in this
case are calling hard-coded data but
they could go ahead and call an api so
let me show you what I mean by this
let's look at something a little more
realistic again I'm slowly getting more
realistic now we're going to go over to
react here we go we're gonna go to wrap
REST API as a side note all the demos
I'm showing are up on my github repo if
you go to github.com slash Cori house
all one word then you can also fiddle
with all of this okay so let's go over
to wrap REST API so what I'm going to do
is show you an existing API that is
getting served up by putting graph QL in
front of it what I'm going to do is
start it up again what this is going to
do is start up two different api's on my
machine let me expand this you can see
what's going on
so it started up a local API at
localhost 3000 using JSON server I was
just singing JSON servers praises a
little bit earlier I use JSON server all
the time because as a side note again as
somebody that works in and react a lot I
don't want to hit the real api's I want
to hit mock api's because mock api's are
instant I don't want to have any kind of
delay also mock api's don't go down mock
api's are on my local machine as long as
I can boot my machine I can run that API
so I can code while I'm on an airplane
without paying the 8 bucks to Southwest
so that's nice so let me show you this
is if again if you're not familiar with
JSON server I can do the same thing that
I did with that graph QL set up earlier
where I declare some JSON and it stands
up a restful api for me so I have a blog
posts API right here I can click on it
and you can see here's a bunch of blog
posts I have some authors and I have
some companies and the amount of
configuration that I did to get this
restful api was as simple as me creating
a file over over here to generate the
database oh this looks a little more
involved this isn't actually this could
be far simpler but I won't get into why
it's not here nonetheless you can do it
simply with a file though so what we
have here is a restful api so picture at
the moment that i'm showing you your
existing API traditional restful api
notice that when I go to slash blog
posts it gives me blog posts I could
also do a post to write new blog posts I
could do a delete verb to delete blog
posts all of that is supported through
JSON server but what we want to do is
wrap this API with graph QL so that we
can enjoy all the goodness that I showed
you guys at the beginning so to hit the
graph QL endpoint I can come right over
here localhost 5,000 and
now I am hitting that same end point so
I can come into here and put in I want
to see posts and I want to see the ID
and I want to see the title and hit play
and there we go I am consuming that
RESTful API that's running on that other
port graph QL is taking what I'm sending
it here and then forwarding those calls
on so let me show you how this works if
I go over to source and go to index this
should look familiar to you
because here I have setup graph QL like
I did in that previous demo in fact this
code is I believe identical if not it is
extremely similar so the thing that's
different though is my schema let's go
look at the schema itself and this is
where things get interesting notice that
in my resolver when I request an author
or I guess I just requested a post so
let's look at the post when I request a
post look at what my resolver does it
makes an API call it calls my existing
restful api so this is my suggestion for
the practical thing that you could do
when you get back into the office is you
stand up a graph QL server and you call
your existing restful api s and now you
get to be a hero because all the sudden
people can request pieces of your data
set people can request relationships and
your data set you now have documentation
that is strongly typed that is generated
that you can interact with right there
in the browser you get all of that
through graph QL now I imagine you're
wondering how the heck this works one
thing to show so I come into here let's
just watch what happens here
when I make a network request I need
to pull this up a bit so I can see it so
here's this network request so what I
just did
anytime that I make a query in graph QL
I am making a post so there's a decision
made how many of you remember being in
an argument on your API whether you
should use get put post and delete see
hands all over the place I have to graph
QL you don't get in that argument you
use post for everything it's a decision
that's made it's part of the
specification and some of you would go
wait why just post because it works
because it's fine you are sending some
data to the server and what determines
whether you're changing data or writing
data is if it's a query it contains the
word query or if you omit the word query
then it assumes that it's a query if you
want to do a mutation you put the word
mutation in the query so let's see
what's actually getting sent over to the
server here so here is my request right
down here I've got my query and my
variables I'm not setting any variables
here I won't really get into variables
just for sake of time but you can
parameterize your queries and then pass
variables and those placeholders but if
I take this right here notice that what
this is right here that is my query I
know that's kind of small let me see if
I can size that up a bit and actually if
I copy this and maybe paste it into into
a text editor oh well that doesn't look
great either because it actually brings
over those silly Chrome's little things
so all those little arrows are returns
but nonetheless what you can see is the
string is the query so when you are
doing dev in graph QL here's the flow
that tends to happen you go over to the
graph QL server or graph to the
graphical interface here you write your
query and when you've seen that your
query returns the data that you want or
that the mutation does what you want you
copy this and then you paste it into
your code
as a string usually a perhaps in a
separate file if you want but now you're
done you know that it works it's already
tested complete it gets sent over in
your posts and we can see an example of
that as well let's go one step farther
I'm going to hit ctrl C here so I am a
react developer and I enjoy working with
that's let's do the react vanilla graph
QL github so now we're gonna get a
little more real again let me hit NPM
start this is going to start up a react
application how many of you are working
in react
lots of hands okay quite a few how about
angular that's the other half of the
room we're done okay no view probably
quite a few in view okay all right so
this is a simple github issue search and
if I click search it's going to make a
call to the github API and then return
back some information given this looks
ugly but it's simple it does the trick
and it is returning data using graph QL
we can come in here and see if we go to
the network tab let me refresh this
again and then hit Search in here oops
and then I will pull this up again we
can see the query right here and the
data getting sent right there there is
my query for it oh wait no that's not
the one I want this old that's not the
query I just ran is it no it wouldn't be
let me clear this and then rerun it this
is the request yes so right down here
see the there's my query organization of
Facebook repository react and here's the
query itself that got sent so it made a
post it sent some data on that so let's
go look at the code for this project I'm
going to close stuff out and
show how this plays so what I want to
show is react application nothing really
to see here this is the entry point and
I want to emphasize you don't have to
know react to understand what I'm going
to show here what I want to show is I
made a query right here what I did was I
said go to github xapi I and then pass
along the query the query that I sent it
is right here get issues of repository
now this query doesn't quite fit on a
screen because I'm zoomed in a lot but
if you look at it I'm passing over some
arguments here because I'm saying I want
a certain organization I want a certain
repository and then this whole cursor
thing is just there for pagination but
nonetheless you can see that it is
copied out of graphical pasted it into a
string and I'm done and if you don't
like this sitting in the app file go
ahead and put it in a separate J's file
because it's a string nothing special
about it so that's the way you end up
holding your queries now notice that
when I make the call I don't need any
extra tools to make this happen I'm
using Axios to make a post here but I
could use plain fetch I could use XML
HTTP requests and that's that now since
I'm interacting with github I do need to
send a bearer token just for
authentication there but I want to
emphasize here to you that this part
looks no different than any other API
call that you might make but notice it's
pretty simple though because I'm always
going to do a post and I'm always going
to hit API github com regardless of how
I want to interact with github this is
another important lesson with graph QL
in this world of micro services that
we've had the last few years people have
been standing up service after service
after service and the problem starts to
become discovery you go okay what api's
are out there so people have different
ways of handling discovery people will
create a service read your registry
sometimes that's as simple as a website
that lists all the different micro
services and has links to each of their
swagger Doc's is a pretty popular way
well with graph QL discovery can go away
because you can
one graph QL endpoint for the company
and that sounds completely unscalable
but it scales and Facebook has proven
that by the way the way that it scales
is remember how I showed you set up a
schema for your server
well that schema file you can split that
schema file into as many files as you
want so you could say this team owns
this schema file this team owns this
schema file and then in the end you glue
them all together for the graph QL
server so discovery is no longer a
problem for github for instance because
github knows all of our data is right
here one other thing to emphasize
anybody heard of OData okay quite a few
hands so data do you look at this and
think hmmm that's kind of like Oh data
and when I first saw this that was my
first reaction to and I remember when
OData came out I was just gangbusters
excited because I thought this is the
second coming it's gonna be amazing and
everybody's gonna do oh data so this
isn't the first time I've gotten really
excited about something in technology
this was the problem with Oh data OData
was open by default when OData came out
it was effectively saying here's my
database have at it and if you didn't do
some work people were going to pummel
you it defaulted to open and that was in
retrospect a mistake and largely they've
addressed that over time with new
versions graph QL is precisely the
opposite of that because with graph QL
you start out completely closed you do
nothing until you decide to do something
and I want to emphasize this because
when I created this schema over here for
this let's look at this schema for this
earlier demo notice oh no I want to look
at this this one instead okay notice
that I make the decision right here I
decide what objects I want to expose and
I also decide in my
Alvar what happens I decide what
parameters what arguments must be passed
in to my queries and my mutations so
github is a wonderful example of this
because I was over here I was showing
you
this github query down here no notice if
I'm going to ooh that's not helpful if
I'm going to make a call to github
github does not let me say select star
from repository and you can imagine why
what github says is if you want to query
us for our repositories you need to give
me an organization you need to give me
the repository so I have to say I want
the Facebook organization and I want the
react repository and you can think about
the sequel that gets generated behind
the scenes that's a very efficient query
because now it's select star or select
specific fields from table so as a graph
QL developer it is right over here that
you hold all the power in the world
because you are deciding how open you
want to be with your database if you
don't want people getting all the data
or making expensive queries then you
design your resolver accordingly you say
we're not going to let you do a select
star on user we're going to require that
you give us a user ID will give you user
users by ID but not the whole thing so
this gives you a real clear hand in the
performance implications of your
deployment for graph QL we've looked at
a lot of code so before I shift over to
some slides I'm guessing some people
have some questions hit me anybody
okay so your question is can you show me
an example of what a mutation would look
like I don't have an example of you
mutation ready but the way it would look
would be the same as what I'm showing
you right here except the word query
would be replaced with the word mutation
and then oh well you're pointing out
that this one is doing a get request so
yes if I was hitting a RESTful API that
expected me to do a send an HTTP delete
on a deletion for instance then I would
have to make that HTTP call here that
way I would have to pass a delete verb
and those sorts of things so what I want
to clarify is resolvers or a function
that gets data that's it so that
function may reference hard-coded data
like I showed earlier it may make an API
call or it may query a database directly
because you don't need to call some
other API with graph QL you can hit the
database directly in fact if any of you
in here are using Postgres sequel there
are two different services that will
generate a graph QL database or I'm
sorry a graph QL API directly off your
post grade Postgres database which is
really quite impressive
I'm sorry I didn't catch that
okay so your question is you okay so
your question largely is how do I
differentiate between a mutation and a
query right here in my resolver you you
would end up yeah looking at the is this
a mutation or is this a query and then
writing your reer resolver accordingly
right there yeah because your you're
right when I'm talking about I'm making
a call to post here yeah so this is a
simpler example yeah it's so you had a
hand back over here I do not in here
know so interacting with different
databases is going to look different and
like that was one thing I wanted to show
is like if you chose to use hashira has
an interesting tool graph QL engine that
lets you stand up graph QL api's right
on top of Postgres so that even
eliminates some of the boilerplate that
I'm talking about here of effectively
what it does is looks at your schema and
then is able to generate a it looks at I
should be more specific
it looks at your Postgres database
schema and then generates a graph QL
schema from it reading those types so
that can that precise answer is gonna be
different and you point out I should
have put an example in here of hitting a
real DB but I don't I'm showing wrapping
REST API and honestly in my experience
most people are wrapping their api's
using graph QL today one of the one of
the reasons is you could think about
graph QL as the backend for the
front-end potentially now I think longer
term we're going to see people
increasingly just standing
graph QL and right in front of their
their DBS but today what tends to happen
is people have invested a whole lot of
money in their existing services and
there's nothing fundamentally wrong with
them it would just be nice if we stopped
getting into arguments about get versus
post and how to do pagination and how to
do filtering and how to do sorting I
mean all of those things become painful
conversations and if I surveyed the room
you'd find different people with with
different preferences there so it's
that's one of the big pieces of value is
having the spec yeah yes so his question
is what about caching so caching is an
area that is trickier admittedly with
graph QL because you are making posts
and also think about this I could end up
caching this query but if someone else
makes this query that's not a cache hit
because it's a different query it
returned different data so your numbers
of cache hits are likely to go down to a
degree although if you think about this
your application is a given application
is good to request a certain shape
pretty consistently so you're going to
get cache hits from a given app quite
often but if you have a lot of different
apps that are hitting the same data
sources in different ways they're not
going to get cache hits so that becomes
a problem that way so that that is
definitely one of the the downsides but
that said it is certainly solvable yeah
so that's a good question so when you
write a failed to fetch oh wait am i
hitting one that I'm not running anymore
that's probably why so your question is
what happens when I'm chaining when I've
got this nested data in here well if you
have imagine in this case you've got a
posts endpoint and you've got an author
endpoint so yeah you're gonna have an in
plus one problem here because
behind-the-scenes yeah you're gonna get
the post and you get ten posts back and
then you're gonna make a call to author
ten times to get the author data and
that's systemic - if that's the api's
that you have to work with at the moment
that's reality for you and in fact today
if those are your ap eyes that's what
your application has to do that's
precisely why people go out and they say
well let's add some other AP eyes on top
of this and let's limit the chattiness
so graph QL can't magically fix that if
you are wrapping your existing ap is the
decision for that comes down to then
maybe we should enhance our ap eyes that
were calling or maybe we should call the
database directly so you have control
there yeah so the question was what
about authorization well keep in mind
your resolver is a function that
retrieves data so your resolver you have
all the power to choose what to do there
and in that way yes you're also on the
hook to say okay can the person who has
just requested this do what has been
asked unfortunately I don't have a good
example of the authorization side of it
but if you think about the resolvers as
functions that get the data it's also
that resolvers responsibility to to vet
whoever's making that request well at
least yeah if a barrier talk is involved
that would logically be what you'd be
checking although that's one way to have
the aussies story yeah lots of good
questions
all right oh yes I don't remember
offhand and I can't I can't ever
remember requesting a blob type from
graph QL if I remember right it's kind
of weird sorry
yeah no that's a good question I think
what people would normally do is request
the string instead the the file path and
then request it that way and largely
that's what I would end up doing with
restful api is as well give me the data
that shows me how to get to it and it'll
make the request separately yeah no
that's a good question I'm trying to
take notes I will add that to the next
talk so okay so let's let's talk slides
for a second because I just showed you a
lot of stuff let's talk about the pain
that you might be feeling today
transformations as in when I request
data is it in the shape that I want
often it's not so you end up having to
change that data who ends up doing
transformations on the client lots of
people over fetching as in I wanted the
banana but you gave me the whole jungle
you know that's that's a problem this
happens a lot too
or under fetching where I request the
user and I need all these properties but
the API only gives me half of them right
now so somebody's got to go crack open
the code and do a deployment to give me
these other properties that I wanted
long chains of API calls and this gets
to what the gentleman in the back was I
was pointing out where you're going oh
man so I've got to make a call to post
and then I've got the author data and
now I've got to go get all the author
data and then I've got to get all the
comments data based on each one of those
posts so chains go away graph QL waiting
for API changes there's another thing
that I like I tend to code against mock
api's a lot because I don't want to wait
for that an API team to create those
changes with graph QL as long as the
data's there I can get it in the shape
that I want
how much time have we spent as
developers arguing over API design get
versus put versus post versus delete
filtering sorting deletions pagination
how should we document our app or API
all of these things go away because the
graph QL spec says here's how you do it
so choosing graph QL makes a hundred
decisions for you when you're going to
call your API think about how you have
to go over then into JavaScript and you
have to use Axios or use whatever may be
to call your API with graph QL that pain
is you need a something that makes a
post and it takes the query that you've
already written over in graphical so
that pain goes away how many of you know
when somebody's calling a specific query
and what properties they're using on
those queries I'm doubting anyone does
but that's a reality that can happen
graph QL and of course documentation is
important solve the problem graphical is
the canonical standard there are others
out there like playground which are
extremely similar to graphical but the
docs are solved and discovery if you
have one endpoint that has all your data
exposed discovery is no longer an issue
go out to the graph QL endpoint and use
it so contrast that with graph QL you
don't have to do transformations there's
no problems with over fetching or under
fetching because you're asking for
precisely what you want you're not
waiting for API mods because you asked
what you for what you want you're not
chained API calls because you make one
call to get the data in the desired
shape no more debates on API design no
API proxy boilerplate your Doc's
you set a boolean to say yes I would
like Docs and you probably want Doc's
discovery not a problem to me this is
something we should celebrate I mean
this is a good stuff wait for it there
we go that escalated quickly yeah that
this kid yeah I don't know if his dad
showed him that
it's worth seeing twice yeah so I will
say as a side note this slide deck if
you want to dive more into graph QL this
slide deck is really intended for a full
day on-site training session but I'm
just using pieces of it in here and I
focused more on our demos along the way
but so you can go out to the repo and
see more about some of these things that
I'm going to blow past here this this is
what is so important though this is what
sets graph QL apart from rest in general
rest is not a specification graph QL is
a specification what rest is is an
architectural pattern it's an
architectural it's a way to structure
api's but it is not specific see rest
came from Roy fielding writing a
dissertation years ago and a
dissertation is not a specification
those are very different things and
that's precisely why we've gotten into
long arguments about get in post and
what hypermedia means and how you're
supposed to handle hypermedia what these
anchors should look like what these
links between different resources should
be because we don't have the Bible for
rest we don't have a spec for that now
given I will say there are some good
specifications out there if you want to
stay in the realm of rest I would
encourage you to look at JSON API
anybody using JSON API I figured not
because no one out here said that they
were able to request certain properties
JSON API specifies that it's called
sparse field sets and with JSON API you
can sit in the query string and say here
are the particular properties that I
want for the user or for the vehicle
whatever entity I'm requesting so what
graph QL is what I've shown you here
it's a query language and it has a type
system and it works with any language
there are libraries for c-sharp and for
Java and Python and Ruby and I've shown
you know
note is the canonical implementation and
also used by Facebook so it's the most
mature but good examples for just about
any tech out there one HTTP endpoint
which is nice because it means on the
client you write very little boilerplate
code you need to make an HTTP call now
there's some other good tools out there
like Apollo I'm not going to spend time
going into Apollo but it makes things
even easier you can be very declarative
about getting data from graph QL but
it's not tied to any database technology
it's a specification and a type system
so on the server what I showed was we
described the data structure and on the
client you request the exact data that
you want now I want to clarify you look
at this chart this is a chart for graph
QL popularity and that looks pretty
promising graph QL has been growing
quite quickly but if I put rest on there
this gives you a sense of where we are
graph QL is coming and graph QL is
growing at a rate where it's going to be
quite a while before it potentially
becomes more popular than the rest style
that so many people are using but I want
to emphasize like this room I asked in
here how many are using react
lots of people using react well if you
rewind look at this chart for the
longest time angular was king but react
slowly grew grew grew and eventually it
dethroned angular as number one on
Google Trends for what that's worth so I
think we are somewhere about half way
along here but I do believe that we are
headed toward a world where graph QL
becomes the majority because of all the
reasons that I've talked about here and
in fact I would I pay attention to are
when people I look up to start diving
into graph QL and singing its praises I
pay attention
so John resin created jQuery and he
wrote a book recently on graph QL and he
feels like it's the successor to rest AP
is his subtitle is actually it's the new
rest so there's that said though I I
know
have a link bait title on this talk but
I really I'm not suggesting that you
throw away your restful api is I think
you keep them running but you end up
potentially using graph QL as the
backend for your front-end because now
you can build you eyes so much faster
okay so I am going to jump past I'm on
slide 20 I got 167 slides
we're on 20 yeah we're not going to do
all these so and the reason I have all
these slides is I spend a lot of time
conveying the oh man I'm really sad that
we didn't get to this one but this is a
reference to rest though have you ever
heard this though when people you get in
an argument about rest and people say
what you can do that with rest what
you're showing right there isn't a
restful api it's the no true Scotsman
problem that every time you say
something negative about something
people go well that's not actually an
example of that thing if it was a real
example it wouldn't have that downside
so getting in arguments about rest tends
to feel very religious because people
are they don't have any specification to
reference it's a lot of different
opinions on these areas so with with
graph QL I know all of these things I
know about versioning and which HTTP
verbs I know about filters pagination
all these other questions are solved I
mean this is this has often been reality
for me as this feeling of I get in an
argument about rest and it's okay what
really is it it's it feels like a moving
goalposts conversation and in fact so I
put out a survey at a previous
conference just to see how many people
were doing some of these different
things and very few people are doing
hypermedia
with rest and in fact quite a few people
how many of you know what hypermedia is
the minority even though the majority of
this room says they're doing rest a lot
of people would say true rest is doing
hypermedia which means when I make a
call to a user there should be a link on
there that allows me to go grab all of
their addresses and should tell me the
the link should tell me how to get there
that was the big idea that Roy
building declared but very few people
have done that so that's made the rest
terminology tricky and if you go look at
when people build restful api is all
these different features in here like
filtering sorting pagination caching
this was from my survey less than half
of people do all these things because
again it's not in the spec I'm if
somebody's got to really tell me to do
it for me to do it
whereas with graph QL a bunch of these
things just happen for free consistent
error messaging interactive Docs being
able to customize the JSON shape being
able to get sparse field sets where I
get just part of that data and then all
of these over here in the green they're
standardized but they're optional so
it's like going from special snowflakes
all of us are restful api today look
different and that way the big downside
of that right now is we don't have an
ecosystem of tools to make them better
over time whereas with graphical
specification we've seen all sorts of
really interesting tools come out
because the specification the
strongly-typed nature of the schema
gives you bedrock to stand on ok so let
me scroll to the end and let's go right
here so my suggestion is this use both
wrap your rest api's for optional use
and people could continue to call the
rest api's directly but what you'll
probably find is once people see how
nice it is to call the graph QL
endpoints and the power that that gives
them and you get it so the good thing is
you can stand up that graph QL API and
make it optional for people see if they
will show up and they will enjoy what's
there because all of this gets solved
that's a lot of good stuff so if you
want to dive farther into this this is
the URL for the repo this has all of the
demos that I showed you today also I
offer consulting services for reacting
graph QL and you can find out more about
me at react yes consulting com
I'm also house core on Twitter there's
tons of links in here to different blog
posts and demos that I found useful but
I'd love to hear from you on Twitter as
well that is my talk I got five minutes
left but I'm gonna give you that time
back I'm gonna sit down up here if
anybody wants to talk shop and ask more
questions thanks for listening enjoy in
DC see
[Applause]